tras la muerte de la reina una larga
dinastía está lista para sentarse en el
trono británico- cuando nació en 1926
isabel segunda era la tercera en la
línea de sucesión durante el reinado de
su abuelo jorge quinto y aún así terminó
al frente del palacio de buckingham
durante siete décadas la abdicación de
su tío eduardo octavo y el posterior
fallecimiento de su padre jorge sexto la
convirtieron en jefa de estado del reino
unido y de la commonwealth con tan sólo
25 años
[Música]
en ausencia de isabel segunda el
primogénito de sus cuatro sucesores
concebidos con el duque felipe de
edimburgo carlos de gales se convertiría
en rey si acepta el encargo es el
primero en la línea de sucesión el
segundo en la jerarquía es el mayor de
los hijos que carlos de gales tuvo
durante su breve matrimonio con lady di
el príncipe william quien casado en 2011
con kate middleton da continuidad al
linaje windsor con sus tres
descendientes por lo que el príncipe
jorge sería el tercero en orden
sucesorio los sigue en cuarta posición
su hermana la princesa carlota que
gracias a la reforma legal de 2011 que
eliminó la discriminación por género
puede pasar por delante de su hermano
menor el príncipe louis que queda quinto
en la herencia del trono agotados los
descendientes de william y kate la línea
dinástica salta al segundo hijo de
carlos de gales el príncipe harry quien
alejado de la realeza no pierde su
condición innata de príncipe ni su sexto
rango como sucesor de la corona
británica por lo que sus hijos con megan
marco arze y lilibeth diana mantienen el
séptimo y octavo lugar a pesar de las
públicas acusaciones de sus progenitores
a la casa real
en estos meses mientras estaba
embarazada todo al mismo tiempo había
conversaciones paralelas sobre que no se
le otorgaría seguridad ni un título y
también preocupaciones y conversaciones
sobre qué tan oscura sería su piel
cuando naciera el turkestán my people y
sports las recriminaciones no hicieron
temblar la popularidad de la familia
windsor que en total cuenta con 18
personas en la fila al trono de hecho la
aprobación de la reina isabel segunda
superaba el 83 por ciento en 2020 según
un estudio de estatista mantener esta
fama es todo un reto para cualquier
heredero de una monarquía en pleno siglo
21 y la pregunta ahora es si la
monarquía sobrevivirá después del
reinado de isabel según